now the result
I used to Graham Brady the returning
officer for the conservative and
unionist party leadership election
declare that the total number of
eligible voters was one hundred and
seventy two thousand
437. the turnout in the election was
82.6 the total number of votes rejected
was 654.
the total number of valid votes given to
each candidate was as follows
Richie sunac 60
399 Liz truss 81
326. therefore I give notice that Liz
truss is elected as the leader of the
conservative and unionist party
foreign
it's an honor to be elected as leader of
the conservative and unionist party
I'd like to thank the 1922 committee the
party chairman and the conservative
party for organizing one of the longest
job interviews in history thank you very
much
I'd also like to thank my family my
friends my political colleagues and all
of those who helped on this campaign I'm
incredibly grateful for all of your
support
I'd like to pay tribute to my fellow
candidates particularly Richie sunac
it's been a hard-fought campaign I think
we have shown the depth and breadth of
talent in our conservative party
and I also want to thank our outgoing
leader my friend Boris Johnson
foreign
[Applause]
you got brexit done you crushed Jeremy
corbyn you rolled out the vaccine
and you stood up to Vladimir Putin
you were admired from Kiev to Carlisle
friends and colleagues thank you for
putting your faith in me to lead our
great conservative party the greatest
political party on Earth
foreign
that our beliefs resonate with the
British people
our beliefs in Freedom in the ability to
control your own life in low taxes in
personal responsibility and I know
that's why people voted for us in such
numbers in 2019
and as your party leader I intend to
deliver what we promised those voters
right across our great country
during this leadership campaign I
campaigned as a conservative and I will
govern as a conservative
foreign
s we need to show that we will deliver
over the next two years
I will deliver a bold plan to cut taxes
and grow our economy
I will deliver on the energy crisis
dealing with people's energy bills but
also dealing with the long-term issues
we have on energy Supply
thank you
and I will deliver on the National
Health Service
but we all will deliver for all for our
country and I will make sure that we use
all the Fantastic talents of the
conservative party our brilliant members
of parliament and peers are fantastic
counselors are ms's
rmsps all of our counselors and
activists and members right across our
country because my friends I know that
we will deliver we will deliver or we
will deliver and we away
and we will deliver a great victory for
the conservative party in
2024. thank you thank you